addio santo certo questa è la tensione
cinque giorni prima di natale dicembre
20 sì è vero
effettivamente due calcoli li so fare
anch'io aprile i regali di natale presto
perché non posso aspettare natale come
tutti i bambini normali tipo questo che
si è girato con i ragazzi siano su furbi
non so come si chiami questo gioco non
dette il tè il tipo si chiama è
effettivamente se devo aprire mi regali
di natale in anticipo sono un bambino
perché c'è anzi corro faccio rumore ok
comunque a prescindere un videogioco che
inizia con la prima missione che aprì i
tuoi regali natale in anticipo è un
gioco della madonna comunque in tutto
questo io non ho capito dove dovrebbero
essere mi regali natale che da che mondo
e mondo si mettono sotto l'albero
però non c'è un cazzo sotto l'albero
quindi che cosa dovrei aprire ti apro la
mamma non ho mica nello scantinato i
regali natale entriamo nello scantinato
a vedere questi bellissimi regali dove
dove ritrovare questi maledetti regali
eccoli qua papà hai provato a
nasconderli ma non hai fatto i conti con
fa vj che trova tutto vediamo se avevano
regalato alla playstation 5 cos'è questa
merda non mi piace non mi piace
apriamo gli altri non si possono aprire
vabbè mi accontento volevo il cd di gigi
d'alessio volevo perché mi hanno
regalato questa cosa che bella ok lui
mangia davvero trova del cibo in frigo
cosa come devo portarlo in cucina
però devi stare zitto zitto che fai
casino
grazie al mio compleanno il compleanno
di gesù ho capito un attimo un attimo
dargli da mangiare se non fa casino
capito ma già [ __ ] più blush in the
ring road to clean the tenth è ok dove
la living room
guarda questo qua ti giuro su dio sono
trovavo potevo schierare che mi stava
facendo impazzire partenza del backup
non ho capito cosa voglia dire ma va
bene vuol dire che devo portarlo giu che
fastidio il regalo di mer non potevo
chiedere una scarpa rame c'è un nuovo
cimento food trovato vabbè basta
torna dentro torna dentro la scatola
[ __ ] va a dormire o guarda era
meglio giocare a tombola con la nonna
giuro che sarebbe stato meglio non
rispondere al telefono se vuoi che io
non risponde al telefono devi scrivere
gli sfondi pure fronti
era la pizza niente quindi basta anima
dormire perché la porta è aperta sentite
io prendo l'uovo e tornò a dormire ok
per ball
cos'è sta roba a sono collezionabili e
basta cioè non servono a niente bene
buona norma vorrei chiudere la porta ma
non sono abbastanza alto sono un anno
quindi buonanotte a tutti
e stato bello nanna ragazzi miei questo
gioco se promette bene promette un sacco
bene quattro giorni prima di natale devo
arrivare più al natale investire sul
rumore questo rumore ma ci devo andare
per forza io non ci posso andare i miei
genitori o due anni
che problemi avete devo andare io sono
sherlock versione piccola chi è che fa
bordello malizia eccolo cioè la
lavatrice semi kathu furbi che fa il
casinò basta basta prendereste uova non
ne prendono anche più
mi spieghi chi ti ha dato
l'autorizzazione di infilarti nella
lavatrice brutto essere peloso viola non
mi fa un cazzo ridere a me che mi sono
svegliato alle 4 di notte
senti ma perché so che ti fanno anche
intelligente o soltanto rincoglionito
ogni capitolo lasciandoli con deception
fan
divertiamoci trova un vaso nello
scantinato con cui giocare un vaso devo
trovare un vaso nello scantinato
eccolo va un vaso cosa ci puoi fare con
un vaso spiegami che bello questo gioco
mi piace tanto
greg flash ai trova una flash la ed ecco
che cosa vuoi fare
ad ok questo farti una domanda furbi
della minkia perché mi sono alzato la la
notte per venirti a cercare qual è il
mio problema non lo so va bene ok
protette il backup che hai dovuto
portati senti e ti devo chiudere con il
nastro isolante per non farti uscire
stai zitto mir reti ragazzi mi dà
veramente fastidio sto tizio prova vai a
dormire bene la torcia posso tenerla che
carina mi piace mi piace potete
regalarmi la torcia per natale invece di
sto furbi di merda ragazzi poi ce
l'avevate il furbi quando eravate
piccoli perché se no non avete veramente
un'infanzia anzi ce l'avete avuta
migliore [ __ ] buonanotte non sono
tenuti ad aprire la porta non solo due
anni ci pensano i miei dicembre 22 tre
giorni prima di natale grazie di
ricordarmelo sempre che non so mai
contare perfetto che problemi a quel
giocattolo dei problemi
sarà mica qua dentro
ma che cos'è sta roba
c'è c'è un altro furbi che non ne
bastava uno a schiacciarmi cazzo pure tu
e l'ho trovato bisogno che faccia da
prendere la cassetta
[Musica]
si faccia di merda trova furbi stesso
madonna dove sei
perché devi fare bordello fatti una vita
cosa c'è adesso caroni ma porta furbi a
mamma
sì perché mi devono dare i pupazzi
inutili una playstation la playstation
non parla è per questo che ho iniziato a
giocare videogiochi mamma mamma era
l'altro pupazzo insomma se mia madre
hanno capito dai tua madre quello che
minchia è andatevene a [ __ ] luca
ragazzi sta torcia è una figata ve lo
dico ecco perché mi servirebbe come
adesso ma ma fa un rumore quando è
vicino se lo senti non ho fatto in tempo
a leggere questo che alla fine se lo
senti
spegni ti svegli torcia l'incasso spegne
non si spegne ma ma attacca soltanto
quando fai casino bene non sono il sito
io soffitto sono sito sono zitto va a
dormire subito porca pro ieri è brutto
gioco che è diventato era bello
all'inizio e va bene sti cazzi e vai a
dormire veloce vai a dormire corri c'è
il bagno non lo guarderò assolutamente
adesso lo guarderò poi chiamati perché
se devo andare a dormire buonanotte a
tutti bene ma anas comiche bene ragazzi
credo che abbiamo ufficialmente
sbloccato il cattivo di turno che è
mamma dove resistere ancora due giorni
pensate come commesso perché ci devo
andare io che ho due anni e non ci vanno
i genitori che problemi avete al
cervello
sai che sta sarebbe tanto wow andare a
dormire
che palle non sia presa porta però la
faccio a ok fatti come fanno i miei
genitori che fanno bunga bunga in
silenzio senza rompere cassa tutto il
quartiere ok c'è anche questa
possibilità lo sapevate
prendi furbi all'altro l'altro lascio
qua va bene
ai del sic nascondino touch the friends
to start ii game sopravvivi per 30
secondi
ok giuliano io di io devo nascondermi
no io devo cercare una scocca armi
nascondermi se stai zitta porca [ __ ] di
tutto un accesso sono passati 30 secondi
sono passati 30 secondi bene faceva che
ansia o vinta a nascondino ragazzi sono
bravo cazzo pensavo di essere non
pensare questo talento trovate il dl al
piano di sopra c'è un piano di sopra
serio ma senza casa mia vuol dire al
piano di sopra non è al piano di sopra
qua vabbè sei stato proprio difficile da
trovare
hide and seek touch the free entro start
che ai maschi domanda da maggiorato
stronzo anni fa un casinò ci manca solo
che io debba veramente anche da lì da
mangiare sufficiente la batteria notari
carico perché non te lo meriti
[Musica]
ok facile ok sylvain nascondo in garage
[ __ ] che brutto gioco sarà la scelta
giusta nascondersi gara ci spero di sì
prati devi stare zitto
ok devi stare zitto puoi non godere in
questo momento per favore
taglia non ce la fa non ce la farà
arrivare quando ce la fa non ce la fa
non ce la fa a un minuto addirittura
porca a trovare un lavoretto pensavo
fosse 30 secondi ma chi se lo guarda
bene ma fammi capire ci dobbiamo giocare
tanto ancora sto nascondino posso andare
bisogna dormire
eccolo eccolo possiamo andare a dormire
adesso basta basta no dai
le balle va bene la facciamo si vanno
qua e poi lo lo vado giumelli carico la
batteria giusto un minuto e mezzo
si chiama che problemi di stare zitto
zitto è devi stare zitto zitto zitto
zitto perfetto ok cacciarmi caldi adesso
cani
ok noti guai giorno entrano domandare
dico mai nella vita
poi ho sbagliato a questa scelta e vabbè
tara [ __ ] porca che è brutto gioco che
sto facendo che brutto gioco no daccapo
no e allora al finale da capo amica ci
mancava un minuto e mezzo dai ce la
posso fare ragano sento non possa andare
dove lo prima non vado dov'ero prima
perché io sempre queste idee di merda ma
veramente di merda che non c'è luce il
tipo e non sono io che mi cadde addosso
sono cioè luce è lui che si caga dose fa
casino
quindi lui sta zitto solo se le barre
sono tu davanti e se c'è luce io che
ansia
ora sei stronzo
porca [ __ ]
io ci arrivo luciano in ultimo vi prego
resisti resisti non si è fatto da quanto
è difficile basta parlare stai zitto
porca [ __ ] fatti i problemi ai
madonna sportello sto facendo
ti sto dando da mangiare stai zitto
ok è un secondo chun due mani basta
ragazzi se volete che io l'ho continui
fatemelo sapere perché per adesso per me
è ok sempre contento di giocare a queste
cose
meraviglioso lasciando mi piace mi
raccomando ragazzi miei spero che il
video vi sia piaciuto è stato po strano
giocare a the tail si chiama se la luce
pure un nome torno chiamarlo furbi
assunto io chiamo furbi sono
trasgressiva dei ragazzi spero che i
video vi sia piaciuto cosa deve fare un
commento
mi piace anche i vari social che come
noi vi sono tuttavia scrizione eserciti
siete lì ci picchiamo il prossimo video
tela ragazzi